halo high altitude bloßen auf madeira
und ich dachte ich nämlich einfach mal
ein tag mit um zu zeigen wie soll das
leben ist ne als allererstes zeige ich
euch aber unsere geisteskranke bude weil
wir haben ziemlich dickes haus
wintergarten wohnzimmer 1 küche
wohnzimmer zwei wohnzimmer drei
schlafzimmer 123 schlafzimmer vier und
das beste an der ganzen wohnung unsere
dachterrasse mit blick auf punkten wie
vielleicht hört gibt es hier den einen
oder anderen straßenhund bau wir wurden
gestern schon angegriffen
nicht so leist punkte ich das auch nicht
einfach nur hier durchgehend geschafft
so was ja ein tor wie lukas leo sind
alle in der stadt am drehen und genau da
gehen jetzt auch in welche stadt fragt
ihr euch
guckt euch diesen ausblick gibt hier
keine richtigen bürgersteige das macht
die situation nicht unbedingt leichter
dazu kommt dass die portugiesen fahren
als hätten in ihrem leben nichts anderes
getan und keinen millimeter abbremsen
diese straße hier führt einfach in beide
richtungen also leute fahren hoch und
runter was man nicht vergessen darf wir
haben februar und
über 20 grad sind durchgehend nur mit
kurzer hose und t shirt unterwegs abends
an pulli und das reicht komplett manchen
einwohnern hier ist es doch schon zu
kalt und die tragen dann einfach so
winterjacken und so wird gefragt
gerade durch zufall hier auch seine
markt gelandet hier sind überall frische
früchte das ist richtig
naja mal schauen ob irgendwas probieren
können da sind die anderen
managerin von canterville comeback an
der comeback next week comeback am 16
diese den sechs euro einfach komplett
unsere touristen falle getappt
[Musik]
wir sind gerade eine stunde einmal
komplett über die insel gefahren wird
auf der anderen seite der insel und ging
es mich ja schon müssen freunde guckt
euch das an das ist geisteskrank da oben
das licht da sebastian ihr könnt euch
gar nicht vorstellen wie sehr ich mich
freue
in einer woche wieder zurück im zwei
grad kalten köln zu sein wie kann etwas
so schön sein diese insel bringt
wirklich alles mit was der insel haben
muss oh mein gott wir sind hier weil
natürliche pools und hier ist die ganze
versammelte mannschaft die gerade auf
madeira ist super super viele
verschiedene leute nirgendwo chance was
ist das hier das wasser ist einfach
komplett blau ich weiß nicht wie sehr
man das jetzt sehen kann wir sind noch
so ein paar fische
das wasser kommt halt da vorne vom meer
hier eingeschlossen und dann ist es halt
komplett ruhig und man kann hier drin
schwimmen richtig krass aber das wasser
ist ziemlich klar einfach mit dieser
kulisse hier was zu hören
okay wir gehen mal ganz nach vorne
bis zum meer aber es echt entspannt wenn
man sich einmal an die temperatur
gewöhnt hat man hier stehen überall
oh mein gott da hilft hier vorne lagen
halt die wellen vom mehr komplett über
deswegen kann ich mit der kamera nicht
dahingehend hatte kann man da rein
springt junge überall ich halte das
sieht so krass aus guckt euch das mal an
was ja aber bitte verletzt sich nicht
und schauen was wir machen
doch ein foto
[Applaus]
du hast du zu uns herein kommt häufig
fenster konnten
jetzt müssen springen
geil
außenaufnahmen ist zumindest klar genug
dass man noch von oben reinschauen kann
wirklich viel zugkraft im jahresplan für
sonntag schon krass wie du oder ich weiß
nicht was kommt
und vielleicht geht es auch wieder in
die natur ist völlig crazy ich weiß gar
nicht wie ich das beschreiben soll was
ich dazu sagen soll
es ist auf jeden fall unfassbar schön
hier gerade das auf der einen seite hat
die berge so krass sind auf der anderen
seite das meer um ist wohl vergessen
euch zu zeigen was wir essen ist aber
kein problem weil man nicht mal vier
stunden haben wir den nächsten termin
den nächsten tisch reserviert wir sitzen
hier mit allen zusammen sind am essen
bei dieser kulisse ist es geistig ich
möchte nicht zurück nach köln bitte
holen sie mich nicht nach köln
warum wir halt hinterher konnten sechs
frauen im keller